Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus was machst du gerade nach
ich Probe gerade du Probst was Probst du
ja also heute Abend ist Generalprobe und
morgen und übermorgen sind drei Konzerte
also ich selber spiele keine Instrumente
ich singe auch nicht ich bin mir sicher
ob das eine gute schlechte Nachrichten
irgendwann mal privat anhören und dann
entscheiden nein also das interessant
ist ich mache das mit meinen Studenten
eine Musikhochschule Hans Eisler machen
wir
Aufführungen zu Robert Musils Roman der
Mann ohne Eigenschaften na das ist
sozusagen dieses Jahrhundert Buch über
das ich irgendwie meine sämtlichen Uni
arbeiten geschrieben habe und das
sozusagen das bedeutendste Werk der
deutschsprachigen Literatur des 20
Jahrhunderts ist das nur wenige gelesen
haben ihr weiß auch keiner versteht ja
es ist jeder Satz ist gut zu verstehen
aber sozusagen die Gedanken fülle die da
drin ist und die schleppend bis gar
nicht vorankommen in der Handlung
sollten das nicht zu einem kulinarischen
Roman sondern eher so eine Art
literarischer Philosophie und das ist
das für mich ist es das Buch meines
Lebens ist und meine persönliche Bibel
ja erzähl warum weil das Interessante
ist Musil war Ingenieur der gleichzeitig
dann später in psychologiephilosophie
promoviert hat und der so beide Seiten
abdeckt weißt du die eines
geisteswissenschaftlers und die eines
Naturwissenschaftlers und der lässt da
quasi immer das Weltbild der
Naturwissenschaften auf die Welt Bilder
der Geisteswissenschaften treffen
und das ist so faszinierend und das ist
in einer so unglaublich schönen
ironischen Sprache und sprachhandlung
geschrieben das ist ein faszinierend das
ist das kannst du dir auf Nachtkasten
legen drin blättern und du findest immer
wieder irgendeinen Satz wo du denkst i
wish eyed dritten Song ja das ist so
schlau und so geistreiche und so okay
aber weil du das ja immer so gut
runterbrechen kannst Richard wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie stehe abends auf dieser
Party rum und will mal so ein bisschen
angeben ja und sagt lass so nebenbei
fallen das liest gerade den Mann ohne
Eigenschaften genau ja und dann sagt er
niemals das ist ja toll und und dann
wäre ich jetzt aber in der verzwickten
Lage dass ich so tun muss als hätte ich
es gelesen und hätte ich es vor allen
Dingen auch verstanden welche fünf Sätze
müsste ich sagen um zu dokumentieren ich
habe den Mann ohne Eigenschaften gelesen
ihr müsst das wissen wann und wo das
spielt ja das spielt im Jahr 1913 und
soll mit dem Ausbruch des Ersten
Weltkrieges Enden bis dahin kommt aber
nicht
na also 1913 1914 ist die Romanhandlung
angesetzt ja und es erzählt wie ein
30-jähriger junger Mann eine Aktion
vorbereiten soll nämlich das 60-jährige
tonjubiläum des österreichischen Kaisers
und das soll toller sein als das
30-jährige Kaiser Wilhelms des zweiten
im Preußen okay so diese tonjubiläum
werden wie wir wissen nie stattfinden ja
Franz Joseph hat vorher sterben und
Wilhelm II wird ins Exil geschickt aber
das wird sozusagen als Aufhänger gemacht
dass man eine ganz große tolle geistige
erneuerungsaktion machen soll und für
Musik ist es die Vorlage alles was es
gibt an Philosophie die Welt Anschauung
das Denken des Militärs das Denken der
Verwaltung das Denken der Börse Jana zu
reflektieren durchzugehen und und und
und er lässt also alle verschiedenen
Perspektiven die man so auf das Leben
und alle Welt Anschauungen die man haben
kann aufeinander breit und davon handelt
der Roman das heißt wenn du du
beschäftigt sich quasi ganz intensiv aus
ganz vielen Perspektiven mit dem 1913
richtig aber tatsächlich geht es nicht
so sehr um das historische Jahr sondern
die Gedanken der Zeit und Musil hat
natürlich hat das gespielt später
geschrieben also der kam auf die Idee so
1920 und hat es dann angefangen so zu
schreiben seit Mitte der 20er Jahre und
ist
1942 gestorben und da war 62 Jahre alt
und das Buch war noch lange nicht fertig
das heißt also hat natürlich alles das
was er dann danach wahrgenommen hat 20
oder 30er Jahre Nazi Zeit nicht ganz so
sehr kommen nur am Rande vor aber auch
verarbeitet in dem Roman und versteht
man wenn man das liest weil wir gerade
ich meine wir haben jetzt dieses Jahr
hinter uns gebracht wieder Krieg mitten
in Europa und die große Frage ist doch
immer wie konnte es dazu kommen und
diese Parallelität ja also was was ich
das Schlimmste Wort für mich in der
letzten Wochen ist abnutzungskrieg das
klingt so was als würden da so ein paar
Panzer gegeneinander schießen und ein
paar Panzer Haubitzen irgendwie
irgendwann auch aufeinander schießen und
man es so eine Abnutzung im Sinne von da
geht einfach Material kaputt es ist aber
nicht Material dass der Körper so ne da
gehen auch Menschen kaputt und da gehen
auch menschliche Seelen kaputt so also
es nutzt sich alles ab menschliche
Körper menschlicher Geist genau und da
wird dann ja immer der erste Weltkrieg
also da höre ich manchmal genau also
dieser stellungskriegt dieser
fürchterliche das ist ja auch damit
gemeint ja und wenn du mit dem TGV heute
ja wenn du wieder zwischen Brüssel und
Straßburg unterwegs bist da fährst du ja
wirklich über die Schlachtfelder des
Ersten Weltkriegs richtig diese ganzen
weißen Kreuze ja ein einmal quer durch
die Champagne ja und dann siehst du dann
dann dann Gräber wo keine Namen drauf
stehen aber das einfach Massengräber
sind dann siehst du wie wie alt die
waren ganz viele gerade hier im Ersten
Weltkrieg 17 18 Jahre alt den alles
genommen worden ist ne jede Perspektive
auf ihr Leben auf Opfer glückliche
Liebesleben Kinder zu haben und so
weiter die alles geraubt ist und so
weiter das sind Dinge die verbergen sich
hinter einem Begriff wie nutzungskrieg
denn in Werdau wurde ja über eine sehr
langen Zeitraum gekämpft ohne dass es
nennenswerten Raum gewinnen gab richtig
in Baden in ihren schützen Gräben und
dann wurde zum Angriff geblasen es gibt
eine faszinierenden Film von Stanley
Kubrick eine seiner allerersten Filme
die er gemacht hat Wege zum Ruhm das ist
der eindrucksvollste Kriegsfilm den ich
kenne und der handelt von diesem
abnutzungskrieg im Ersten Weltkrieg und
bei geht mit der französischen Seite vor
allen Dingen hat auch ins Gericht genau
es geht in dem Krieg aber im Ende nicht
darum wer jetzt irgendwie Schuld hat
oder so ne es geht sozusagen um die
Eitelkeit von von generellen die ähm
Tausende von jungen Menschen verheizen
einfach um 100 Meter Land zu gewinnen
oder irgendein dämlichen Hügel erst um
zu haben und so weiter ja total irre und
die Frage warum du diesen Hügel jetzt
eigentlich erobern willst ja wenn es um
Abnutzungskriege geht denke ich als
Südtiroler immer an diese Dolomiten
Front ne kannst doch bis heute findest
du da die alten Stellungen und so weiter
da haben sich die Kaiser Jäger mit den
Italienern bekämpft und weißt du wer
dabei war Robert Musil der Autor des
Mann ohne Eigenschaften der war exakt da
eingesetzt nein doch das wusste ich
nicht der war da im Ersten Weltkrieg und
hatte relativ kaltblütig drüber
geschrieben also vergleichsweise
unemotional ne siehst du und das ist
genau das was die so was die so
unfassbar prägt ich glaube man muss dann
auch so unemotional darüber schreiben
weil sonst hält man es nicht mehr aus du
musst das wegschließen und wegpacken
richtig du musst du musst im Grunde
genommen deine deine Menschlichkeit
runterfahren genau und das gruselige bei
kriegen ist wie viel Menschen denen das
gelungen ist es nicht mehr gelungen sie
anschließend wieder hochzufahren richtig
ne und und wenn man sich anguckt was da
jetzt schon passiert ist also wenn diese
diese Sätze des amerikanischen
Generalstabs Chefs millili wenn die
zutreffen das beide Seiten mittlerweile
mehr als 100000 Tote zu verzeichnen
haben und man sich jetzt vorstellt
Stoltenberg hat gesagt er kriegt dauert
noch Jahre Wahnsinn dann reden wir
irgendwann 300 400 500.000 Tote auf
beiden Seiten eine ganze Generation
junger Menschen die da verheizt worden
ist also die Vorstellung dass man ein
abnutzungskrieg überhaupt ins Kalkül
aufnimmt und sagt naja das wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich so kommen das ist die
Chronik eine angekündigten Katastrophe
so ist wirklich so man man macht sich
das nie klar aber ich empfehle immer
meine Reise durch die USA in dem
Zusammenhang wenn man wenn man wirklich
auch mal ins Land fährt ja wenn da wo
auch viele Trump Wähler sitzen da
triffst du nämlich nicht nur auf auf auf
eine sehr ländliche Bevölkerung der
trifft doch auf unendlich viele
Veteranen dieses Thema der Veteran ist
habe ich in Amerika erst begriffen als
wir wirklich anfingen so durchs Land zu
reisen jeden Tag nehmen sich im Schnitt
us-kriegsveteranen das Leben musst du
dir mal vorstellen Wahnsinn die
vegetieren in Zelten da vor sich hin ich
habe das gesehen in Arizona ich glaube
in Phoenix war's Wahnsinn dann gibt's
immer diesen Wetter und stay ja diesen
diesen Tag an dem man der Veteranen
gedenkt aber dann werden sich da werden
wird erzählt man sich dann gegenseitig
Heldengeschichten aber dass ich täglich
tagtäglich 20 von denen umbringen das
erzählt man natürlich nicht und ich
kenne mich an die an die Geschichte von
von einem jungen Mann 28 Jahre alt schon
hieß der der war unter anderem im Irak
stationiert und der hat nie darüber
gesprochen was er da so macht und so
weiter hat immer davon geträumt in diese
US Army reinzugehen und seine Mutter hat
immer gesagt mach das nicht du bist da
nur Kanonenfutter Herz dann trotzdem
gemacht ist nach Afghanistan gegangen
bis heute was die Familie nicht so
wirklich was er darüber gemacht hat
seine Mutter hat später in einem
Interview erzählt Mama wir müssen dort
Kinder umbringen und meine Kameraden
sind tot und dann kam der irgendwann
zurück und lebte dann ein vermeintlich
normales Leben und hat sich dann
irgendwann in einer Wohnung mit einer
giftigen Pflanze selbst das Leben
genommen hat sie einfach umgebracht
haben Karfreitag 2011 und wenn du jetzt
noch mal überlegst nein in den
gewissen Zeiten des Vietnamkrieges sind
58.000 amerikanische Soldaten die kann
man ja ziemlich gut zählen gestorben
vietnamesischer Seite gehen die Zahlen
weit auseinander und redet so von
mindestens zwei Millionen Kriegstoten
oder schwerstversehrten oder verseuchten
aber 58.000 amerikanische Soldaten und
überlegt man all die Aldi Filme die es
gibt ne auch über etwas was du gerade
sagte selbst die die Rambo Filme ne das
ist ja das gleiche Motiv und es gibt ja
ganz ganz viele andere also das große US
amerikanische Trauma der Kriegs
Heimkehrer der kriegsgeschädigten und so
die diese Gräuel gesehen haben und ich
habe ja hier schon mal gesprochen von
Tschetschenien Krieg diese
eindrucksvolle Dokumentation weiße Raben
was was den russischen Soldaten wurde
die in Tschetschenien eingesetzt wurden
und solche grauen gesehen haben erlebt
haben durchgeführt haben und so weiter
und so weiter und wenn ich mir das jetzt
in dieser Dimension des Ukraine Krieges
vorstellen hier sind ja auf beiden
Seiten offensichtlich schon mehr als
doppelt so viele Leute spielen wir
US-amerikanische Soldaten im
Vietnamkrieg und dann keinerlei Hoffnung
keinerlei Perspektive auf ein Ende
das ist schon Markus das ist wir haben
wir vor einem Jahr als haben wir hier
gesessen und nur ändert sich daran du
warst deprimiert ich war total
deprimiert weil ich mir eines ausmalen
konnte ja dass das sozusagen eine ganz
tiefe Zäsur sein würde und dass ein
unglaubliches grauen angerichtet werden
würde und das ist ja auch passiert ja da
kann man schon mal leichte verzweifeln
darüber ja total und ich ich merke auch
du weißt nur wie wir haben uns ja wir
haben sehr intensiv darüber diskutiert
haben darüber gestritten ich ich wenn
wir in dieser Woche jetzt noch mal drauf
schauen und es ist ist die Woche ja und
alles redet darüber was ist da
eigentlich passiert am 24 Februar
dann habe ich mittlerweile das Gefühl
ähnlich wie du auch ich näher mich
sozusagen
wieder deiner Position an
die ja immer war das das das kann so
nicht weitergehen wir können nicht
einfach immer weiter diese diese Gewalt
eskalieren
wenn ich höre was da gerade in München
passiert ist wenn ich höre von dieser
vermeintlichen chinesischen Initiative
dieser Friedensinitiative ich habe da
ein totales Dejavue und ich glaube nicht
nur ich erinnerst du dich in 80er Jahren
friedensmärsche
Bonner Hofgarten und so weiter dabei ja
und und was was war der Hintergrund
Richard ich meine ich ich führ mal ganz
kurz mal meinen Gedanken zu Ende ja ich
höre die Chinesen die sagen wir starten
jetzt eine große Friedensinitiative dann
hörst du dass der Chef Diplomat über
München nach Moskau reisen will um das
mit Putin zu besprechen das klingt
erstmal alles gut aber was wenn die
Geschichte dahinter die ganz andere
Geschichte ist wenn die Geschichte
dahinter genau die des Bonner Hofgartens
ist wenn die Geschichte dahinter die ist
dass diese Geschichte in Wahrheit längst
abgesprochen ist diese vermeintliche
Friedensinitiative von Putin längst
begriffen ein abgekartetes mieses Spiel
man trifft sich dort und sagt ja ja klar
bin ich total dafür dafür Putin ja ich
natürlich will ich Frieden ich möchte
gerne Friedensverhandlungen und zwar zu
den jetzigen Konditionen Kapitulation
sozusagen der Ukraine was auch immer
territoriale Geländegewinne und so
weiter das heißt du du es läuft auf
Bedingungen hinaus von denen du vorher
schon weißt dass werden die und das
können die sogar nicht akzeptieren
natürlich nicht genauso übrigens hier
umgekehrt einer der die Bedingungen der
Ukraine die die das wieder rausrücken ja
das so unrecht angeeigneten
kriegerischer eroberten Landes
einschließlich der annektierten Grimm
wissen wir auch werden die Russen nicht
machen so und jetzt der zweite Gedanke
Richard wenn das so ist und die
antizipieren das alles die wissen das
ganz genau die wissen aber auch wie
gespalten unsere Gesellschaft in dieser
Frage mittlerweile ist und die Debatten
bin sehr gespannt wie du das
wahrgenommen hast auch die Diskussion um
jemanden wie Jungen habermaß und andere
ja
Sarah Wagenknecht war in dieser Woche
auch bei uns in der Sendung die das Land
ist wirklich zutiefst gespalten und wenn
du dir vorstellst die stellen sich jetzt
dahin und sagen pass auf dass das machen
wir so und die Amerikaner die Europäer
werden das so nicht akzeptieren dann ist
es ein Leichtes für die russische
Propaganda genau das dann zu streuen die
Erzählung umzurinnen und zu sagen guck
mal wir wollen ja aber dieser Westen die
wollen das partout nicht die bösen
Amerikaner das kann man ja verhindern
also wenn man meint dass die Chinesen
hier ein komisches Spiel treiben das
eigentlich nur eine einzige Funktion hat
nämlich zu zeigen dass sie Russen
Frieden wollen und der Westen nicht
warum machen wir dann nicht von
westlicher Seite ein großes Gespräch
sein Angebot und dann werden wir ja
sehen wie die Russen drauf reagieren
erinnerst du dich an acht an die 80er
Jahre Richard deswegen dieses Dejavue da
was genau so Aufrüstung Spirale es geht
immer weiter und dann kommt plötzlich
die Russen und sagt die Sowjetunion
damals und sagen dass auf ein wir wollen
das gar nicht wir sind doch eigentlich
eine friedfertige macht jetzt lass uns
doch mal gemeinsam miteinander reden und
dann entsteht diese tiefe Spaltung
meine überleg mal Willy Brandt der gegen
seinen eigenen
SPD-Kanzler Helmut Schmidt auf den
friedenseemus aufgetreten oder erinnere
ich mich dran genau um die Grünen
einzubinden die gerade entstanden sind
und das war doch genau die Situation und
das Land war zutiefst gespalten und ich
finde die die Analogie geht bis in die
Details hinein wenn ich sage Bonner
Hofgarten ich meine das was am Sonntag
in Berlin stattfinden wird ich glaube
das hat das Zeug ähnlich groß zu werden
Stichwort Ali schwarzer und Sarah
Wagenknecht und und untergehen viele
viele viele Menschen hin und es ist
diese diese zutiefste gespaltene
Gesellschaft die sich nicht mehr sicher
ist wo das Ende jetzt muss man ja sagen
letzte Gedanke im Hintergrund höre ich
dass die Amerikaner die große Sorge
haben und das höre ich auch in den
Hintergrundgesprächen nach der Sendung
z.B dass die Chinesen längst viel mehr
Teil dieser ganzen dieses ganzen Krieges
sind als die offiziell zugeben also
nicht nur Halbleiter in die Ukraine
liefern
nicht nur russisches Öl abnehmen und es
dann wieder weiterverkaufen das heißt
dieses ganze System stützen sondern
offensichtlich auch ganz konkret darüber
nachdenken Waffen zu liefern und das
bedeutet zu einem schon sozusagen
unerschöpflichen Waffenarsenal der
Russen kommt jetzt noch das
unerschöpfliche Waffenarsenal der
Chinesen und dann höre ich Anthony
blinken den amerikanischen Außenminister
der sagt wir werden die Ukraine so lange
unterstützen wie es nötig ist und das
sagen alle anderen auch und ich denke um
Himmels willen Waffen starrend auf der
einen Seite waffenstarrend auf der
anderen Seite und dazwischen diese armen
Ukraine die noch in viel viel größerer
Zahl sterben werden und unter die Räder
kommen das ist gerade die katastrophale
Situation eins zu eins deiner Meinung
das ist das was gerade passiert der
Krieg eskaliert immer weiter und er
eskaliert deswegen immer weiter weil die
militärische Logik
ja natürlich klar ist also erst ich
meine gehen wir ein Jahr zurück also
ganz am Anfang die Frage wollten wir ja
nur Unterstützung machen indem wir Helme
liefern sondern war sukzessiv
Verteidigungswaffen jetzt haben wir zum
ersten Mal mit dem Leopard Panzer
Angriffswaffen jetzt ist die Rede von
Kampfflugzeugen oder von von sehr
weitreichenden Raketen mit dem man Ziele
in Russland treffen kann es geht immer
weiter und weiter und weiter und wir
haben ja genau gesehen bei dieser
Diskussion um gelbe orangene rote Linien
die gibt es nicht wirklich in der
militärischen Logik existieren die nicht
in der militärischen Logik kommt immer
der nächstmögliche nächstbeste sinnvolle
Schritt um noch mehr Schlagkraft zu
entwickeln um diesen Krieg zu gewinnen
und abseits der militärischen Logik
passiert eben nichts na also wir finden
nicht eine zweite Schiene ja neben
dieser militärischen eskalationslogik
wie wir sagen wie wir aus der ganzen
Nummer wieder rauskommen und was das
irgendwann und irgendwie und von
irgendeiner Stelle wieder bremsen könnte
dass die Gesellschaft gespalten ist
finde ich ja nicht schlimm also in einer
solchen komplizierten bombastischen
schwierigen moralischen politischen
strategischen Frage als ich das für
normal dass nicht alle Menschen in der
Gesellschaft da unterschiedlicher
Meinung zu sind erstmal sind
Informationsstände unterschiedlich aber
was sie wichtiger ist ist auch man hat
da unterschiedliche Haltung er wird von
unterschiedlichen Gefühlen dominiert die
einen haben ihn erst seine Angst ja die
anderen sind denken nach wie vor man
kann Putin das nicht durchgehen lassen
und das ist ein Angriff auf den Westen
und wenn wir das Verlieren ja wer weiß
was dann als nächstes kommt und so
weiter also es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche Emotionen die da im
Spiel sind vor allen Dingen sind erstmal
Emotionen die dann zu Gedanken werden
und wenn den anderen ist es diese diese
Angst vor der totalen Eskalation und vor
dem Atomkrieg und hat auch nicht eine
Seite irgendwie von Natur aus recht ja
also es gibt keine höhere Instanz die
jetzt sagen kann die Moral ist eindeutig
auf der Seite und eindeutig nicht auf
der Seite es gibt für beide Positionen
gibt es Argumente und da muss man sich
ausführlich mit auseinandersetzen da
muss man gucken wie man seinen eigenen
moralischen Kompass in dieser
schwierigen Frage justiert
was mich stört ist dass wir nach wie vor
so aber nicht darüber reden ja und du
hattest gerade aber Maß genannt ja
Jürgen Habermas ist der bedeutendste
lebende deutschsprachige Philosoph 93
Jahre alt 93 Jahre alt mit einem
gigantischen Lebenswerk und der wirklich
für die Demokratie in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland also hilfreicher kann man
als Philosoph gar nicht sein sag mal
zwei Sätzen warum ist dieser Mann so
wichtig weil der wird immer wieder so
als Instanz genannt aber die meisten
glaube ich verstehen gar nicht warum der
so wichtig ist also wenn ich jetzt ganz
ganz kurz zusammenfasse und das ist eine
lange Geschichte würde ich sagen er sie
Soziologen ne Philosoph von Soziologie
deutschen den Nationalismus mit
ausgetrieben und in das ihn
verfassungspatrioten gemacht das ist
eine Formulierung von ihm ja dass wir
also nicht stolz darauf sind Deutsche zu
sein als irgendwelchen ethnischen
rassistischen oder was weiß ich was für
Gründen sondern dass wir stolz sind auf
die Werte unserer Verfassung und wenn
wir darauf stolz sind dann müssen wir
auch so leben dass diese Demokratie eine
lebendige Demokratie ist aber mal selber
hat ja noch den Vers 93 Jahre alt hat
also im Pubertätsalter gegen der Krieg
zu Ende und diese Aufarbeitung der
Nazizeit und dieser Versuch eine
wirklich funktionierende liberale
Demokratie hinzubekommen die wirklich
demokratisch ist die wirklich
funktioniert und das alles in einer Zeit
der 50er Jahre ne wurde dann zum Teil
die alten nazi-richter noch im Amt waren
und so weiter also er hat zur
Demokratisierung
des Bewusstseins der Menschen in der
Bundesrepublik alles das geleistet was
man als Philosoph leisten kann das ist
eigentlich sein Lebenswerk abgesehen von
vielen anderen Sachen natürlich sehr
früh sehr kluges Buch über Medien
geschrieben der Strukturwandel der
Öffentlichkeit dann habe ich
meditationsschrift Thema also sehr sehr
gut versucht hat zu erklären inwiefern
Medien eine zentrale Rolle für das
funktionieren oder nicht funktionieren
von Demokratie Hinspielen und auch das
natürlich wieder heute kein ganz ohne
interessantes Thema also total ehrlich
gesagt spannender
so und ich was mich einfach wundert ist
man muss er hat jetzt plädiert dafür
dass er hat übrigens nicht explizit
gegen Waffenlieferungen geredet aber er
hat natürlich noch mal ganz ganz
deutlich darauf hingewiesen dass dieser
Krieg nur durch Verhandlungen zu Ende
geht und das merkt man dass man das viel
ernsthafter versuchen sollte als bisher
und sich nicht damit begnügen sollte der
jeweiligen anderen Seite immer nur zu
unterstellen sie wolle sowieso nicht
verhandeln dass dieser Text schon wieder
wie der erste Text den er schon mal
geschrieben hat weil es hat zweiter Text
zum Thema mit einer vehement angegriffen
wurde und jetzt was was mich wirklich
auf die Palme bringt sind das
irgendwelche hier gelaufenen
Journalisten ja sich ein Ortsteil ja
über den geistigen Zustand
und über den moralischen Zuschnitt von
Jürgen Habermas erlauben ja dass der auf
einmal da als alter Trottel mit falscher
Moral und was ihm alles unterstellt wird
was er nicht sieht und so sagt ruhig
Alter weißer Mann ja aber zum Teil noch
sehr sehr viel übler ja also wirklich
sagt dem Motto der olle hat doch nicht
mal alle Latten am Zaun ich meine was
ist das für ein respektloser Umgang
abermaß weiß genau ja das ist nicht so
ist dass alle die das lesen eins zu eins
seine Meinung teilen sollen ja einfach
nur drüber nachdenken und Sie müssen es
auch noch nicht mal lesen genau
was ist der letzte der ein Problem hätte
mit jemanden der anderer Meinung ist
also der ist ja sozusagen der Vertreter
des diskursiven er will ja sozusagen
dass wir uns vielfältig darüber
austauschen und so jemand ja damit mit
dicken Kanonenkugeln da abzutun und so
weiter nur weil man die Meinung nicht
teilt
das steht unserer medialen
Öffentlichkeit extrem schlecht zu
Gesicht so geht man damit nicht um
Robin Alexander den ich sehr schätze hat
dieser Tage auch darüber geschrieben und
hat quasi wahllos also es war ging es
gar nicht gegen Carlo Masala ja die den
ich übrigens sehr schätze ja Professor
in München Bundeswehr Universität der
sehr häufig recht hat mit dem was er
sagt ist Professor für internationale
Politik na dann der Uni der Bundeswehr
München und hat natürlich auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz dann
wichtigen Part und so weiter der der
sagt über diesen Beitrag live gold finde
jemanden der dich so sehr liebt
respektiert und achtet wie Teile der
deutschen Elite den russischen ergressor
ja das ist das ist also wie kann man
sowas schreiben oder wie kann man das
was Melnik davon sich gegeben hat der
ihn als übelsten Putin Troll und Schande
für die deutsche Philosophie Melnik ne
die deutsche Philosophie so gut kennt
dass er genau beurteilen kann und auch
noch schreibt kann und Hegel und so
weiter würden sich Sch und so weiter ein
kann der heute leben würde ja ich meine
man kann abermals auch gerne Immanuel
habermaß nennen weil er sozusagen der
Stellvertreter kann es auf Erden ist ein
Kant hätte vermutlich an die gleiche
Position wie die die haben Maß hat und
dass man dann hingeht und selber keine
Ahnung von Philosophie gar nicht weiß
worüber man redet und dass dieser
abgesetzte twitter-ding großen Teilen
unserer Medien ist auch noch wert ist
zitiert zu werden und damit
multipliziert zu werden das ist doch
eine Katastrophe ist doch keine
Qualitätskontrolle mehr da Robin
schreibt es sehr interessanter Gedanke
sagte die der Mechanismus dahinter war
schon in der Flüchtlingspolitik und auch
in der Corona Politik zu beobachten und
schreibt dann wörtlich ein Ton
angebendes Milieu einigt sich sozusagen
auf eine Weltsicht und macht alle nieder
die Einwände erheben und schreibt dann
sehr interessanten Satz und wen man
nicht als rechten die Familien kann den
macht man lächerlich
und sagt und jetzt erwischt es dann
sogar Habermas den man lächerlich macht
und wenn man den lächerlich macht sagt
er weiter dann kann es im Grunde jeden
treffen ich meine Carlo Masala das ist
ein kluger Mann und der der sehr
differenziert das ist nicht einer der
mal eben so sowas raushaut ich frage
mich manchmal ob diese Verkürzung bei
Twitter oder überhaupt in den sozialen
Medien und das dazu führt dass man
sozusagen ah sehr stark vereinfachten
und verkürzen muss aber vor allen Dingen
dass man auch pointiert zuspitzen muss
um überhaupt gehört zu werden und dann
geht's halt auch mal schief und dann
geht's halt auch immer ganz ganz oft
schief und deswegen würde ich ja nur
sagen warum jemand wie Caro Masala von
dem du sagst das sind intelligenter
Mensch absolut warum Twitter dann das
passt ja nicht zusammen wenn ich ein
Medium habe in dem ich mich nicht
intelligent ausdrücken kann dann sollte
ich es nicht nutzen da kann man ja kann
man ja ziemlich schwierig bei 200 80
Zeichen aber in der Zuspitzung bist du
natürlich gehört ne in der Zuspitzung
findest du statt wir reden doch auf
darüber Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie ne ja
gut ich ich wie du weißt verzichte
darauf und du verzichtest soweit ich
weiß auch da drauf ja ja absolut ja es
gibt auch ein Leben jenseits von Twitter
ja das ist richtig aber das würde bei
mir nie zu einem Reflex führen zu sagen
dann verteufeln wir jetzt deswegen
Twitter was was man einfach nur merkt
ist sozusagen diese nee ich finde das
per se ein eine sehr gute und auch
demokratische Veranstaltung und gerade
dann wenn es einem persönlich nicht
gefällt und ich kann ein Lied davon
singen ja wenn man wenn man es mal so
richtig abkriegt das ist aber alles okay
ich ich bin damit fein der Punkt ist nur
finde diese Sache hier dieser Krieg ist
zu ernst als dass man dann so schreiben
genau dieselbe Formulierung wollte ich
gerade machen ist nur eine wirklich zu
groß zu dramatisch zu tragisch zu blutig
und so weiter als dass man hier auch so
so eitelkeitsfäden austrägt ja oder oder
dass man so jemand heißt das hat doch so
eine intellektuellen Feindlichkeit zum
Teil gegen abermals weißt du da so diese
schrumpfschwarzen sind Philosophen
sowieso alle keine Ahnung da ist so eine
Haltung hinter die ist ganz ganz
unangenehm und die steht auch unserem
Land nicht gut zu Gesicht also im Land
der Dichter und Denker ja die Dichter
und Denker so als sowieso zu Idioten zu
erklären sofern sie nicht die gleiche
Meinung haben wie man selber ich meine
das ist schon ziemlicher Verfall der
Debattenkultur
Nummer zurück zu dem worum es wirklich
geht Richard das gerade mal so aufgebaut
ja dieses Szenario und ich bin nicht der
einzige der das so sieht also wenn da
jetzt wirklich die Chinesen einsteigen
ich erinnere mich an mehrere war ich mit
mir ging es wegen kalter Schauer also
runter als ich das hörte man die die
Amerikaner warnen die Chinesen seit
langer Zeit nicht in diesen Krieg
einzugreifen und zwar im Sinne von
liefert den keine Waffen aber die
offizielle chinesische Position wenn man
mal genau hinguckt auch jetzt wieder was
da in München geredet wurde auch von
Seiten der Chinesen dass das ist eine
harte Kampfansage gegen den Westen und
dann kommt das und dann kommt das
sozusagen mit dieser mit dieser
Friedensinitiative wie man es dann nennt
aber manchmal denke ich möglicherweise
ist das einfach sozusagen als ja als als
Empathie für die Welt getarnte
Niedertracht über die wir hier reden in
Wahrheit wird er im Hintergrund ein ganz
anderes Spiel gespielt und die Frage ist
Richard ich schließe das nicht aus was
du sagst aber aber ich schließe das
nicht aus kann alles sein aber wir haben
beim letzten Mal ein Podcast über China
gemacht china hat ein ganz ernsthaftes
Interesse das ist möglichst schnell zum
Frieden in der Ukraine kommt das halte
ich nicht in keiner Form irgendwo für
verlogen oder Teil eines miesen Spiel zu
Melanie sicherlich hat aber China hat
auch ein Interesse daran dass der Westen
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt das habe ich
aber beim letzten Mal schon gesagt die
wollen weder das Russland gewinnt also
sie wollen schon gar nicht das Russland
die Ukraine erobert das wollen nicht
Chinesen nicht aber die Chinesen wollte
auch nicht dass der Westen mit
militärischer Gewalt ein Land wie
Russland besiegt weil sie dann davon
ausgehen die nächsten Jahre sind sind
sie das ist die die die Chinesen haben
und die sagen die dürfen diesen
militärischen Triumph nicht haben weil
dann wird es noch übler das ist
chinesische Perspektive also nicht dass
ich die jetzt Teile und das ist meine
Meinung ist aber es geht darum zu
verstehen warum ich mir vorstellen kann
dass die Chinesen tatsächliches
Interesse haben an einem wie auch immer
kompromisieren ja kannst kannst du uns
mal mitnehmen weil du sagtest Bonner
Hofgarten da war ich damals dabei und
ich habe gerade versucht diese Analogie
zu zeichnen
wie war das damals was war die Situation
also ich war ich war 1983 na 82 oder 83
ich war so 18 Jahre alt und die
Situation war ja damals das ist die
Natur doppelbeschluss gab ja von von
Helmut Schmidt und unterschrieben und
dieser Nato doppelbeschluss hatte zwei
wichtige vorhanden das eine war die
Russen hatten mit SS-20 Raketen
aufgerüstet Langstrecken Raketen und die
Amerikaner sitzen ihre Pershing Raketen
dagegen das bedeutet zugleich
Glas im Falle eines Dritten Weltkrieges
Deutschland der hauptleitragende sein
würde weil der Krieg hier stattfinden
würde es gab damals die die
militärischen Überlegungen dass
Deutschland so eine Art tote Zone werden
würde wo die Russen nicht rüberkommen so
und jetzt die Logik ja die Idee war
nicht nachvollziehbar dass wir
gegenrüsten im Rahmen einer
Kriegsstrategie die dazu führt dass er
dann anschließend sogar möglicherweise
amerikanische Raketen heute rum Raketen
auf dem Kopf kriegen das also
Deutschland in jedem Fall der Verlierer
eines solchen Krieges sein würde und wir
deswegen aus der hochrüstungsspirale
raus müssten das war die damalige
Überlegung und das war der damalige
Grund gegen die Stationierung der
hörsching-raketen zu demonstrieren was
von der Gegenseite verlacht wurde weil
die gesagt haben warum demonstrierte
nicht in Moskau die Russland haben doch
auch ihre Raketen richtig na es gab
damals sogar in Bonn ein Flugzeug ich
weiß gar nicht was heute oder
Hubschrauber in den Flugzeug ich weiß
bis heute nicht wer das bist du noch mal
rauskriegen da waren lange transparent
dran und da stand drauf und wir
demonstriert in Moskau da kann ich mich
noch gut dran erinnern das heißt also
dann hieß es wir sind nützliche Idioten
weil wir nur den Russen in die Hände
spielen na Putin gab es noch nicht also
war noch keine Putin Trolle Johanna zu
dem damaligen Zeitpunkt noch weiß ich
nicht brechen hier ist oder ein
dropbox-trolle
aber
im Grunde genommen ging es ja bei dieser
Demonstration auf eine militärische
Logik hin hinzuweisen ja die in dieser
Form überhaupt keine realistische Option
sein darf ja aber wenn du wenn du sie
noch mal die einfach die schiere Zahlen
mal klar machst ne 300.000 Menschen
glaube ich ja das Jahr aber in den 60er
70er Jahren hatten die Amerikaner bis zu
7000 taktischer Atomwaffen in Westeuropa
seine gigantische Zahl und der Grund
dafür waren ne dass man die Russen für
konventionell
hielt genau und jetzt ist es im Grunde
umgekehrt ne ja heute ist es heute ist
es umgekehrt ja ja und deshalb hält
Russland an diesem taktischen Atomwaffen
zur Abschreckung fest weil sich die
Verhältnis umgedreht hat richtig das hat
tatsächlich so übrigens interessant war
die während des Kalten Krieges war das
atomare Verhältnis zwischen den USA und
den Russen bis Mitte der 80er Jahre
eigentlich bis zum Ende des Kalten
Krieges immer ungefähr gleich
und zwar waren die Amerikaner immer
etwas siebenfach überlegen es ging also
wenn wir vom Gleichgewicht des
Schreckens geredet haben dann war das
tatsächlich in sieben zu eins Verhältnis
aber dieses eins war aus amerikanischer
Perspektive schrecklich genug das heißt
die Amerikaner wussten zwar sie würden
diesen dritten Weltkrieg gewinnen diesen
Atomkrieg aber sie wussten auch dass die
Russen mit ihren Langstrecken Raketen
wahrscheinlich Kalifornien
in pulverisieren würden und eine atomare
Bedrohung in für die USA darstellen
Wahnsinn ja ich weiß noch wie das damals
gleich schwer war ne auch diese
Vorstellung es kann jederzeit und wir
wissen ja auch ne es hat ja mein Unfall
gegeben und da gab es einen russischen
Offizier der dann letzte Sekunde dann
den den Befehl zum nicht gegeben hat auf
den roten Knopf zu drücken und so
und mein Gott weißt du diese Freude das
los zu sein also für mich war das das
allerbeste war am Mauerfall und die
ganzen Konsequenzen die das hatte um
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion und so
weiter war dass diese diese dieses
ständige Blei was da in der Luft lag die
die die die die Vorstellung dass es zu
einem Atomkrieg kommen kann und dass
manchmal nicht viel fehlt dass das weg
war als eine unglaubliche Erlösung
empfunden mein damals war es wirklich so
für den Fall ne dass die Sowjets in
Westdeutschland oder auch nur in West
Berlin einmarschiert werden
hätte der der Kriegsplan der Amerikaner
hat vorgesehen sämtliche Atomwaffen auf
einmal gegen alle Ziele in Russland und
China einzusetzen Sprengkraft sagt
Kaplan 7000 Megatonnen es hat ungefähr
200 Millionen Menschen getötet und zwar
auf einen Schlag und es gab zeitweise
musst du immer vorstellen
16000 verschiedene Ziele allein auf
Moskau waren ungefähr 700
nuklearspringen Köpfe gerichtet und
umgekehrt natürlich auch also dieser
komplette Overkill das ist der totale
Wahnsinn und man hat das Gefühl genau
diese Spirale bewegen uns wieder rein
jetzt auch wenn man Bilder aus Moskau
sieht und dann werden ich meine moskau
ist neben Washington die wahrscheinlich
am besten bewachte statt dieses Planeten
und allein um den Leuten den der
Bevölkerung von Moskau klar zu machen
achtung da draußen gibt es diesen
imaginären Feind ja hat Michael Thumann
kürzlich bei uns hingewiesen deren
fantastisches Buch über dieses Putin
Regime geschrieben hat Kollege von der
Zeit sagte der fangen die dann an
irgendwelche gut sichtbaren
verteidigungs-ding auf Dächer zu
montieren irgendwelche Raketen und so
weiter obwohl alle wissen die gibt es
bereits aber jetzt macht man es noch mal
sichtbar und dann geht es bis zu dem
Punkt an dem man sonst so ein Hokuspokus
aufbaut und in Moskau an weiß
irgendwelche Gräben ausheben zu lassen
Putin und seine Leute um sich
vermeintlich zu verteidigen
vor den bösen ukrainischen Nazis die
jetzt demnächst in Moskau einmarschieren
werden diesen ganzen Hokuspokus baust du
nur auf ja damit du glaubhaft sagen
kannst wir kämpfen da in der Ukraine
gegen diese bösen Nazis das ist so ein
solcher Wahnsinn kriegsvorpommern
Politiker veranstalten ja genau und um
Leute sozusagen
aber jetzt sag mal jetzt haben wir so
viel darüber gesprochen ne dass diese
diese eskalationslogik nicht so
weitergehen darf das heißt also die
militärische Logik darf nicht die
einzige Logik sein dann sinnvoll im
Atomkrieg so oder so was wäre dein
Vorschlag also was würdest du sagen
musst jetzt passieren damit das nicht
unendlich so weitergeht ich ich weiß du
im meinem Beruf ist es als als
Journalist das zu beschreiben was da
passiert ich ich ich sehe das was dich
Chinesen da gerade machen ich würde so
gerne glauben dass das alles wirklich
ernst gemeint ist aber wissend wer die
beiden sind um dies da geht
würde ich da mal ein großes Fragezeichen
hinter setzen habe das gut aber wenn die
chinesische Initiative aus den von dir
genannten Gründen nicht glaubwürdig sein
soll ja sondern eigentlich nur eine
einzige Funktion hat was so das ja
gerade erklärt im Westen zu spalten
Jahren und vor allen Dingen sie sich
selbst rein zu waschen wir wollen ja
Frieden und die anderen wollen ja nicht
und so noch uns zu spalten ne also
diesen diesen Keil den wir haben die
chinesische Initiative erstmal positiv
gesehen weil ich denke wenn irgendjemand
vermitteln kann dann kann das ja nur
jemand sein der Macht und Einfluss hat
also Luxemburg kann das nicht ja also es
muss ja irgendwie dann haben wir die
Türkei geredet ne der ehemalige
israelische Premierminister hatte sich
Angeboten zu vermitteln aber dann wollte
irgendwie auch keiner haben nee also es
wäre es es muss ja jemand sein der eine
ganz große Rolle spielt so und da bleibt
ja nicht mehr viel übrig und die
Chinesen sind sicherlich nicht im
klassischen Sinne neutral und die haben
auch nicht zu beiden Seiten den gleichen
Abstand das ja alles richtig und
trotzdem braucht man einen dritten um
überhaupt ein Schritt in diese Richtung
zu machen deswegen warum von Anfang an
schon alles als Teufelswerk dämonisieren
ohne dass er da ganz sicher sein können
ja wie gesagt ich ich will das gar nicht
tun ich ich finde nur diese diese
Parallelen da über die 80er Jahre über
die wir auch gerade gesprochen haben
dieses vermeintliche Angebot um am Ende
dann festzustellen dass so das wollen
die alles gar nicht in dem Fall die die
Sowjetunion sondern der da geht dieses
Wettrüsten einfach komplett
unkontrolliert weiter das ist das ist
das was mir Angst macht und wenn ich
dann zum Beispiel jemanden höre der
nachweislich wirklich immer wieder das
Gespräch mit Putin sucht der sich diese
langen Telefonate gibt ich bin mir
sicher auch von deutscher Seite gibt es
diese Telefonate das glaube ich ehrlich
gesagt auch ich glaube auch dass über
die die inoffiziellen Kanäle dass man da
durchaus miteinander in Kontakt hatte
genau und dann hörst du aber jemanden
der sagt weißt du was schminkt euch ab
die wollen nicht verhandeln die wollen
nicht reden die wollen dass die Ukraine
kapituliert wenn du dir dieses ganze
diese ganze Gemengelage anschaust und
das ist ja das was mich gerade so
deprimiert dann kommst Du irgendwann zum
Ergebnis dass du a gerade nicht
Politiker sein möchtest und deutscher
Bundeskanzler und Grunde auch nicht
französischer Präsident du möchtest
diese Fragen nicht entscheiden müssen
aber du musst es und du kommst
irgendwann zum Ergebnis dass die
Situation so ist wie sie war da ist ein
Land überfallen worden da sind Menschen
morgens zur Arbeit gefahren und auf dem
Weg zur Schule mit ihren Kindern schlägt
vor ihren Augen einfach die Rakete ein
und seitdem ist nichts mehr wie es war
und seitdem die haben keine Wahl die
kämpfen einen verzweifelten Kampf und
zwar nicht so sehr glaube ich um ihre
Heimat sondern um die Art und Weise wie
sie gelebt haben und die wollen keine
russischen Besatzer die wollen nicht die
wollen nicht unfrei sein ich glaube die
Perspektive der Ukraine ist und völlig
klein in diesem Krieg ja ich ich frage
mich manchmal ob die uns so klar ist
weil weil ich dann denke okay wenn das
der alles was ist denn dann die
Konsequenz daraus dann ist doch die
Konsequenz daraus wenn dieser russische
Panzer vor deinem Haus parkt und du
kannst gedanklich runterzählen drei zwei
eins und dann macht es Bumm der hat dann
bist du doch heilfroh wenn du etwas in
der Hand hast um gegen Bumm zu machen
alles andere bist du nur Opfer diese
Logik ist soweit richtig klar nur wenn
das nicht dazu führt dass der Krieg
endet sondern wenn es dazu führt dass
der Krieg noch ganz viele Jahre weiter
geht oder hunderttausende Menschen auf
beiden Seiten sterben um dann am Ende zu
der Erkenntnis zu kommen dass beide
Seiten diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
können dann ist die Frage muss man diese
diese Jahre Stellungskrieg braucht man
die noch ja oder kriegt man irgendeinen
anderen Dreh hin und ich sage ja auch
nicht dass ich hier eine universelle
Lösung habe aber es gibt überhaupt keine
Alternative dazu und anderen dreht zu
finden und was mir wichtig ist wir tun
immer so als müssten wir wenn es darum
waffenschild Stand oder Frieden gibt
endgültige Lösungen schaffen ich glaube
das ist falsch gedacht
ich glaube das Lösungen die man finden
kann auf Provisorien sein können weißt
du es wird sich eine Menge noch immer
Russland tun es wird Nachfolger für
Putin irgendwann geben wir wissen nicht
ob es schlimmer wird oder ob es besser
wird das können wir alles auch gar nicht
einschätzen das weiß auch noch niemand
im Augenblick ja aber wenn man dann
einfach sozusagen den Krieg einfrieren
würde auf einer bestimmten Stufe und
dann einfach die Frage vertagt bis sie
irgendwann auch ihren Sprengstoff und
ihre ihre große Bedeutung verloren hat
in der Frage ob das Dorf oder das Dorf
da in luhans oder in Don jetzt geht's so
Ukraine oder zu Russland gehört oder
Separatisten Gebiete oder was weiß ich
was ist wenn das alles dazu führt dass
Hunderttausende von Menschen nicht
sterben müssen und diese Frage dann
vielleicht in fünf oder zehn Jahren noch
mal geklärt wird ja vielleicht mit einer
anderen Regierung in Moskau unter
anderen vorzeichnen anderen politischen
Großwetterlage also alles das sind doch
auch Optionen die auf dem Tisch es geht
doch gar nicht um ein entweder oder in
dieser Situation dass sowieso nicht
herbeigeführt werden kann nein aber
merkst selbst nur das sind so viele
Events so viele aber so viele hätte
könnte müsste so viel Konjunktiv drin
ich ich nehme nach diesem einen Jahr
jetzt für mich so mit und das berührt
mich ehrlich gesagt bis heute
dass Menschen und das zeigen auch die
Umfragen in der Ukraine wenn es um die
Frage geht was bist du bereit zu tun
wenn es um deine eigene Freiheit geht
dass die bis heute alles tun um diese
Freiheit zu verteidigen das berührt mich
der sind die Markus alle Ukraine ja wenn
du die die Umfragen anschaust Richard
sie weißt du wie viele junge Männer aus
der Ukraine in Deutschland sind ja ich
kenne jetzt die Zahlen nicht alles
welche die nicht ihr Leben verlieren
wollen an der Front Richard das wirst du
immer haben aber es gibt eine
beeindruckende Zahl von Ukraine die
bereit sind alles zu tun um dieses Land
und ich glaube es geht noch mal es geht
um gar nicht so sehr ums Land weil
dieses Land hauen die den einfach gerade
komplett kaputt aber es geht um ihre Art
zu leben ja eben ich frag mich immer wer
diese Gebiete bekommt in denen der
hauptkrieg stattgefunden hat jetzt
gerade die Gebiete um bachmut rum zum
Beispiel
ich meine wie will man das alles jemals
wieder aufbauen welches der beiden
Länder also weder Russland noch die
Ukraine hätte das Geld oder die
Möglichkeiten dazu das wird doch ewiges
Brachland der Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
kostet doch jetzt schon wahrscheinlich
ein Millionenbetrag wo soll der denn
herkommen das Geld kann er nicht alles
gedruckt werden die wirtschaftlichen
Prognosen für die nächsten Jahre im
Westen sind jetzt nicht ganz steile
Konjunktur ich weiß nicht aber also ich
ich sehe ich sehe in diesem Krieg nur
Verlierer egal wo nachher die
politischen Grenzen ist richtig der
Krieg ist doch jetzt schon für beide
Seiten grausig verloren für beide Seiten
und für die Menschen die in diesen
Gebieten die so heiß und kämpft sind SAP
und so weiterleben ich meine die haben
sowieso schon die totale Arschkarte da
ist sowieso schon alles kaputt und wird
auch von niemanden so schnell wieder in
blühende Landschaften verwandelt werden
können ja oder oder hier Mario Pool und
militopol und Kriegs zerstörten Städte
der soll denn das alles wieder aufbauen
wo soll denn die Wirtschaftsleistung
dafür herkommen ja und wenn der Krieg
jetzt noch länger geht und noch länger
und noch länger dann geht noch mehr
kaputt und noch mehr kaputt und dann ist
es auch nicht mehr aufbaubar ich glaube
wir werden die Aufgabe immer bewältigen
müssen das haben wir mit Deutschland
auch geschafft Denkmal dran wegen
welchen Blutzoll dieses Land entrichten
musste um am Ende um am Ende dieses
wunderbare Land zu werden dass es gerade
ist und es bleibt einfach dabei die
Ukraine hat nie einer gefragt ob sie
diesen Krieg wollten der wurde den
einfach angesagt ja klar genau und und
deswegen ist ist immer wieder klar
festzuhalten wer diesen Krieg ausgelöst
hat und wir werden 100 Milliarden ja
aber von Anfang an klar wer wer die
Schuld an diesem Krieg führt ja und wer
hier völkerrechtswidrigen anderes Land
überfallen hat über diese Frage haben
wir beide noch nie bei dir noch nie
diskutiert nein aber wenn ich dieses
letzte Manifest von Sarah Wagenknecht
z.B lese wenn es da heißt irgendwie die
diese Eskalation der Rüstung das muss
jetzt endlich mal beendet werden lieber
Herr Bundeskanzler endlich nee warte mal
die Eskalation muss jetzt endlich mal
beendet werden lieber Wladimir Putin das
ist der Text den man dahinschreiben muss
und nicht Deutschland hat diese
Eskalation betrieben sondern es war
schon sehr sehr eindeutig der Mann im
Kreml steht da in dem Manifest ich habe
es nicht gelesen steht da drin
Deutschland habe die Eskalation
Betrieben nein die Eskalation dieser
diese der die diese Rüstungs Eskalation
ja das ist so es tut immer so ein
bisschen so das ist teilweise wirklich
unter Komplex es tut ein bisschen so ich
glaube ich glaube dass alles schwarzer
sehr genau weiß wer diesen Krieg
angefangen hat und ich glaube
dass die Putin auch mehrfach öffentlich
verurteilt hat und auch das mag man auch
gleich zu Anfang des Krieges weit von
Putin weggerückt ist ja und klar zu
machen dass dieser Krieg bei aller
Sympathie die man vielleicht mal gehabt
haben mag Unrecht auf der ganzen Linie
ist und ein Verbrechen aber der Ton ist
dann die Aufforderung geht dann an den
deutschen Bundeskanzler diese Rüstungs
Eskalation ja weil man deutscher
Staatsbürger ist und weil man nur da
Einfluss nehmen kann dass der Grund ja
und auch zu sagen irgendwie wir
vertreten die andere Hälfte des Landes
sie sagen noch nicht Olaf Scholz ist der
hauptschuldiger in diesem Krieg sondern
die sagen es ist deutsche sie können sie
einwirken können ja nur auf den
deutschen Bundeskanzler einwirken und
Sie können keine keine Briefchen an
Putin schreiben die liest ja sowieso
nicht so und das ist doch genau das
Problem genau das ist das Problem das
sind schöne schlussvortrichter hat genau
das ist das Problem hätte ich danke Dir
sehr das waren intensiver Austausch wir
hören uns nächste Woche schönes und
trotz allem gutes Konzert am Wochenende
wünsche ich Dir ja also sind ja
insgesamt drei Konzerte ja ich weiß
nicht wie wäre dein Maßstab Gebäude in
Berlin machen und ich bin ganz neugierig
wird großartig also alles Liebe bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
potstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]